.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich möchte Ihnen
die Geschichte von Georg erzählen.
Georg trennt sich von seiner
Partnerin, weil er - wie er sagt -
seine Lügen nicht mehr aushält.
Er führt mit seiner Partnerin
eine gute Beziehung,
hat sie gern
und fühlt sich ihr verbunden.
Beim Geschlechtsakt aber,
beim Sex mit seiner Partnerin,
gibt es einen Punkt,
an dem er seine Erregung
nicht ohne Fantasien an Jungs halten
bzw. einen Orgasmus auslösen kann.
Georg hält dieses Lügen
nicht mehr aus.
Das hat er sich nicht ausgesucht.
Betroffene sind nicht schuld
an den sexuellen Gefühlen,
aber verantwortlich
für das sexuelle Verhalten.
Ich sammle mich in solchen Momenten.
Einfach für mich.
Ich lasse mir den Prozess oder
den Verlauf durch den Kopf gehen.
Ich lasse mich auf den Menschen ein,
der dann kommt -
mit seiner ganzen Palette.
Und ja, da sind Sachen dabei,
die problematisch sind.
Er hat eine sexuelle Präferenz,
die aussergewöhnlich ist,
die ich emotional
nicht nachvollziehen kann.
Monika Egli-Alge
war eine der Ersten in der Schweiz,
die Menschen mit einer Pädophilie
präventive Therapie anbot -
damit sie nicht Täter
und weniger Kinder Opfer werden.
Heute trifft sie Pascal.
Grüezi wohl.
Ja, willkommen.
- Ja, willkommen.
Sie sagen,
Sie hätten die Erkenntnis gemacht,
dass Sie sind, was Sie sind.
Wie haben Sie das gemerkt?
In der Schule. Mit zehn
verliebte ich mich in einen Jungen.
Aber in dem Alter
weiss man noch nichts von Liebe.
Sechs Jahre später verliebte ich
mich wieder in einen Jungen.
Der war nicht gleich alt wie ich,
sondern immer noch zehn.
Da merkte ich,
dass irgendetwas falsch war.
Pascal würde eigentlich gerne offen
über seine Situation sprechen,
sein Gesicht zeigen
und seinen Namen nennen.
Aus Angst vor Reaktionen
ist das aber nicht möglich.
Alle Betroffenen in diesem Film
zeigen wir daher anonymisiert
und mit fremder Stimme.
Vor 14 Jahren
war das schon schwierig,
als ich die Erkenntnis hatte,
dass ich bin, was ich bin.
Ich verliebe mich in Jungs
zwischen sieben und 13.
Ich verliebe mich nur,
alles andere ist tabu.
Ich finde Jungs schön,
habe aber keinen Wunsch,
mit ihnen Sex zu haben.
In meinen Fantasien schon,
aber das sind Fantasien.
Für mich ist ganz klar,
dass es Fantasie bleibt.
Pascal ist laut eigenen Angaben
nie Täter geworden.
D.h., er hat keine Delikte begangen:
keine sexuellen Übergriffe an Kindern
und auch keine Missbrauchsabbildungen
konsumiert -
im Volksmund unter dem Begriff
Kinderpornografie bekannt.
Pascal ist heute 30 Jahre alt.
Er lebt allein und arbeitet
in einem handwerklichen Beruf.
Seit 14 Jahren geht er regelmässig
zu Monika Egli-Alge in Therapie.
Sie bezeichnen sich
als Kinderschützer.
Mhm. Das ist paradox, oder?
Nein, ich finde das
überhaupt nicht paradox.- Okay.
Weil ...
Sie haben Kinder ja eigentlich gern.
- Ja.
Für mich ist ganz klar:
Ich bin, was ich bin,
ich will aber keinem Kind wehtun.
Von mir geht keine Gefahr aus.
Ich trinke lieber ein Bier
oder schlafe,
anstatt ein Kind zu missbrauchen.
Wie geht man mit einer Sexualität
um, die man nie leben kann?
Das ist anfangs brutal. Das ist so.
Aber ich habe gelernt,
dass ich das beherrschen kann.
Oder wenn ich es selber nicht
schaffe, dass ich Hilfe holen kann.
Wie machen Sie das -
sich beherrschen
und Ihre Sexualität unterdrücken?
Das geht voll
gegen den menschlichen Instinkt.
Aber nach 14 Jahren Arbeit
ist es einfacher, das zu sagen.
Seine Sexualität zu beherrschen
ist ein Prozess.
Aber andere
müssen das ja auch können.
Es gibt die Selbstbefriedigung.
Das ist das einzige Ventil.
Man findet sich damit ab und
man nimmt das als Teil von sich an.
Was fehlt Ihnen am meisten?
Zuneigung fehlt mir
manchmal schon ein bisschen.
Das ist merkwürdig,
weil ich nicht weiss, was Liebe ist.
Ich habe dieses Gefühl
nie richtig erlebt.
Ich hatte mal eine Freundin,
aber das war eher zweckmässig
und halt keine Liebe.
Ich weiss nicht, was das ist.
Das bleibt bei der Begleitung
der Betroffenen immer ein Thema:
"Wie überhaupt?"
Es gibt fast mehr Einschränkungen
als Möglichkeiten,
wirklich glücklich zu sein.
Da geht es nicht um Sexualität,
sondern um eine Beziehung,
um eine gewisse Zukunft.
1 % aller Männer fühlt sich
von Kindern sexuell angezogen.
Sie haben eine Pädophilie oder
wie Expertinnen und Experten sagen,
eine Präferenzbesonderheit
auf den kindlichen Körper.
Davon gehen aktuelle Forschungen aus.
Mindestens jeder hundertste Mann
also.
Auch Frauen sind betroffen.
Wie viele,
weiss man noch nicht so genau.
Auch nicht, wie sich die
sexuelle Präferenz genau entwickelt.
Pädophil sein
heisst aber nicht automatisch
Täter sein oder Täter werden.
Diese Präferenz zu haben
ist nicht verboten.
Das kann man nicht steuern.
Das hat man oder hat man nicht.
Deshalb
muss man das wertfrei betrachten.
Fantasien und Gedanken
sind auch nicht verboten.
gehören einem selber
und schaden noch niemandem.
Sobald es in eine Handlung geht,
wird es problematisch.
Sobald die Präferenzbesonderheit
einen Effekt aufs Verhalten hat,
diese also z.B. ausgelebt wird,
wenn auch nur in kleinen Schritten
Grenzen verletzt werden,
ist es verboten und illegal.
Keine Delikte ist das oberste Ziel.
Wir verurteilen Delikte und wir
verurteilen Taten - und zwar alle.
Diese Haltung ist völlig klar.
Aber wir nehmen diese Personen,
diese Menschen,
bei uns respektvoll in Empfang.
Wir würdigen den Schritt,
etwas zu unternehmen,
um keine Delikte zu begehen.
Ich finde es extrem stark,
wenn sich jemand traut,
diese Telefonnummer anzurufen
und zu sagen:
"Ich glaube, ich brauche Hilfe."
Monika Egli-Alge
leitet ein forensisches Institut.
Ihr Therapeutenteam behandelt
oft Menschen mit einer Pädophilie.
Hallo.
Seid ihr schon fertig?
Ich komme etwas zu spät,
Entschuldigung.
Ah, wunderbar.
Danke vielmals fürs Kochen.
Die Arbeit mit Menschen
mit einer Präferenzbesonderheit
für den kindlichen Körper
ist anspruchsvoll für die Thera-
peutinnen und Therapeuten im Forio.
Das gemeinsam zu machen
ist ein wichtiger Punkt.
Dass man sich austauschen
und alles auf verschiedene Schultern
verteilen kann.
Und dass man einen Abgleich
persönlicher Haltungen machen kann.
Viele Leute wissen viel zu wenig.
Ich anfangs auch.
Durch die Erfahrung bekommt man
einen ganz anderen Umgang damit.
Es ist ganz anders,
wenn man mit diesen Leuten
direkten Kontakt hat.
Man hat das Gefühl,
man sähe es den Leuten an.
Aber wenn man
persönlich vor ihnen sitzt,
sind das einfach Menschen.
Wie ist es für dich?
Du hast sie ja am Telefon.
Wenn ich eine Anfrage kriege,
finde ich es ziemlich stark,
dass sich jemand von sich aus
hier meldet und sagt:
"Hey, ich habe ein Problem:
Ich stehe auf junge Mädchen."
"Ich weiss, dass das nicht geht.
Ich habe nichts gemacht."
Das finde ich eindrücklich
und auch stark von ihnen.
Ich treffe mich jetzt
mit einem Paar.
Ich habe sie in der Krisensituation
kennengelernt,
als er ihr gestand,
was seine Situation ist.
Für mich war das auch
eine anspruchsvolle Situation.
Diese Situationen mit Angehörigen
sind besonders
und emotional auch intensiv.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
(Frau) Man sagt, es ziehe einem
den Boden unter den Füssen weg.
Das war auch so.
Ich spürte nicht mehr,
was um mich herum war.
Ich musste megastark weinen.
In dem Moment
brach für mich eine Welt zusammen.
Ich hatte den Mann kennengelernt,
den ich mir gewünscht hatte:
sehr fürsorglich,
liebevoll, zärtlich und einfühlsam.
Aber jetzt nahm man mir das weg.
Jetzt war das vorbei.
Beides geht ja nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Er kann nicht diese Präferenz haben
und eine Frau lieben,
die älter ist als er.
Das ist mit so vielen Ängsten
verbunden.
Warum ist er mit mir zusammen,
wenn er eigentlich
jüngere Frauen und Mädchen ...
Liebt er mich überhaupt?
Woran denkt er, wenn wir Sex haben?
Da gehen einem
innerhalb von Sekunden
so viele Dinge durch den Kopf.
Es tat wahnsinnig weh.
Das ist unbeschreiblich.
Das kann man gar nicht ausdrücken.
Martin ist um die 30,
seine Partnerin Christina
einige Jahre älter.
Martin hat eine
nicht ausschliessliche Hebephilie -
d.h., der frühpubertäre Mädchenkörper
erregt ihn.
Allerdings nicht nur:
Er kann auch den Körper einer
erwachsenen Frau anziehend finden,
sich in sie verlieben.
Sie setzten sich lange damit
auseinander, wie Sie es ihr sagen.
"Kann ich es ihr sagen?
Soll ich es ihr sagen?"
Es gibt nie den richtigen Zeitpunkt.
- Ja.
Als wir uns das erste Mal sahen,
machte es einfach zack.
Das klingt abgedroschen,
aber es war einfach so.
Es war,
als hätte ein Blitz eingeschlagen.
So war es wirklich.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, ich könne ihr
das nicht von Anfang an sagen.
Ich musste ihr Zeit geben,
damit sie mich kennenlernen
und ich ihr vertrauen konnte.
Ich musste wissen, dass die Bombe
nicht platzt, wenn ich es ihr sage,
dass sie damit nicht hausieren geht
und es für sich behält -
egal, was aus der Beziehung wird.
Dieses Grundvertrauen brauchte ich,
bevor ich es ihr sagte.
Ist es das erste Mal,
dass Sie das einer Partnerin sagen?
Ja. Es gingen mehrere
Partnerschaften dran kaputt,
weil ich es nicht schaffte,
offen darüber zu sprechen.
Ich wusste,
dass es mich erdrücken würde,
wenn ich es ihr nicht sage.
So ein Geheimnis ist nicht toll,
wenn man zusammen wohnt.
Das geht nicht.
- Vielleicht schon,
aber dann baut man die Beziehung
auf Lügen und Ausreden auf.
Das hätte mich erdrückt.
Darum war mir klar:
Wenn ich es ihr nicht sagen kann,
geht die Beziehung auseinander.
Ich spürte, dass etwas los war.
Entweder musste er es mir sagen,
oder ich hätte so
nicht weiterleben können.
Ich spürte einfach,
dass da irgendetwas war.
Ich weiss auch nicht warum.
Geht es kaputt, wenn Sie es sagen?
Weil Sie es sagen?- Ja.
Oder geht es kaputt,
weil Sie es nicht sagen?
Ja, wenn ich es ihr sage,
kann sie mein Leben zerstören.
Meine Grundhaltung ist folgende:
Wenn es rauskommt,
gibt es einen Suizid.
Martin
geht seiner sexuellen Präferenz
für frühpubertierende Mädchen nach.
Er wird straffällig.
Ich merkte relativ früh,
mit 17 oder 18,
dass das, was ich begehre,
immer etwa gleich bleibt.
Das konnte ich lange
ohne Probleme mit mir mittragen.
Aber irgendwann war das Fass voll
und ich wurde delinquent.
Ich konsumierte Internetpornografie
im illegalen Bereich.
Bei der Hälfte aller Männer
mit einer Pädophilie
kommt es im Laufe ihres Lebens
zu einer Straftat.
D.h., sie begehen
einen sexuellen Übergriff
oder
konsumieren Missbrauchsabbildungen.
Laut Studien erleben jedes fünfte
Mädchen und jeder dreizehnte Junge
einmal im Leben
einen sexuellen Übergriff.
Die Hälfte der Täter
ist nicht pädophil.
Hatten Sie mal das Bedürfnis,
das in der Realität auszuleben?
Nein, das hatte ich nie.
Das ist wirklich ...
Die moralische Seite in mir
liess das nie zu.
Es gab sozusagen eine virtuelle
und eine reale Welt.
Vor gut fünf Jahren
wird Martin verhaftet,
kommt für ein halbes Jahr
in Untersuchungshaft,
danach in Therapie.
Straffällig sei er seither
nicht mehr geworden.
Kurz nach dem Gefängnis
lernt er Christina kennen und lieben.
Nach gut zehn Monaten
erzählt er ihr alles -
über seine Präferenz, das Gefängnis.
War für Sie schnell klar,
dass Sie zusammenbleiben?
Ich glaube,
das ging relativ schnell.
Er ist als Mann einfach genial
und so lieb.
Das kann man nicht einfach beenden.
Es war nicht sofort wieder gut.
Es brauchte schon Zeit, um sich
lösen und entspannen zu können.
Ich musste für mich überlegen:
"Kann ich die Beziehung
so weiterführen?"
Wir sprachen viel darüber
und er musste alles erzählen
und mir Hunderttausende Fragen
beantworten.
Ich werde älter.
Will er das wirklich oder nutzt er
mich einfach als Objekt,
um seine sexuelle Seite in
einer normalen Beziehung auszuleben?
Ich fühlte mich zeitweise
auch etwas missbraucht.
Ich war zu dem Zeitpunkt
schon so stabil,
dass man keine Angst haben musste.
- Ich wusste das ja alles nicht.
Aber unsere Sexualität ist so innig
und so ...
Ja ... Nein.
Aber es dauerte eine Weile,
bis ich mich lösen konnte.
Nicht von Gedanken,
sondern mich an eine Sexualität
gewöhnen zu können,
sie geniessen zu dürfen.
Ich glaube, das trifft es besser.
Wenn man so lange in einem Loch
steckt, verlernt man das andere.
Es dauerte eine Weile, aber
mittlerweile stimmt es für uns.
Wir möchten so viel teilen,
geniessen und erleben können.
Es ist wahrscheinlich
für Aussenstehende unverständlich,
aber ich kann damit leben.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
In Basel wartet die neue Aufgabe
für Monika Egli-Alge.
Wir hören immer wieder
von Betroffenen,
dass sie versucht haben,
Hilfe zu holen,
sie aber nicht kriegten.
Der Expertenbericht für den
Bundesrat hat klar herausgefunden,
dass es ganz viele Anläufe braucht,
bis Betroffene
überhaupt irgendwo unterkommen.
Häufig hören sie z.B. von
niedergelassenen Psychotherapeuten,
Psychiatern und Psychiaterinnen
oder auch Hausarztpraxen:
"Da können wir nicht helfen.
Wir sind keine Spezialisten."
"Wir kennen uns mit dieser Thematik
nicht aus."
Der Bund hat deshalb den Kantonen
den Auftrag gegeben,
Präventionsangebote im Bereich
Präferenzbesonderheit für Kinder
auszubauen und sich zu vernetzen.
Tschau.
- Hallo, Marc.
Tschau. Saluti. Gut gefahren?
- Ja, gut gefahren.
Marc Graf
ist Direktor der Klinik für Forensik
der Universitären
Psychiatrischen Kliniken Basel.
Bitte, Monika.
- Danke schön.
Du siehst, das ist der Raum ...
- ... für Gruppentherapien.
Graf gehört neben Monika Egli-Alge
in der Schweiz
zu den führenden Kräften
bei der Prävention für Pädophile.
Der Ort ist super.
Er ist neutral.
Er ist so gelegen, dass man
nicht gleich in eine Forensik,
ein Gefängnis
oder eine Klinik kommt,
sondern in einen ambulanten Bereich.
Das überzeugt mich sehr.
Die Möglichkeiten sind toll.
Ich bin ein grosser Fan
von Gruppentherapie.
Ich bin von der Wirksamkeit
sehr überzeugt.
Wissenschaftliche Studien
sagen auch ganz klar,
man müsse Gruppen-
und Einzeltherapien kombinieren.
Wir machen die gleichen Erfahrungen.
Uns fällt aber auf,
dass es länger braucht,
bis wir jemanden motivieren können,
in die Gruppe zu kommen.
Aber wenn sie in der Gruppe sind,
öffnen sie sich
erstaunlich schneller und tiefer
als in der Einzeltherapie.
Graf hat für die Lancierung
des neuen Präventionsangebots
eine Fachtagung lanciert, an der
auch Monika Egli-Alge auftritt.
Was sind so deine Themen?
Ich berichte,
wie es bei uns angefangen hat.
Wann war das?
- 2006.
2006.
- Vor 14 Jahren.
Super.
Nachdem die Charité
"Kein Täter werden" gestartet hatte.
Wir nahmen ganz früh Kontakt auf
und bildeten uns dort weiter.
Das deutsche Präventionsangebot
"Kein Täter werden"
ist Vorbild für Egli-Alge und Graf.
Im Bereich Prävention ist Deutschland
weiter als die Schweiz.
Wie können wir das einbetten?
Ich machte die traurige Erfahrung,
nicht nur einen Patienten
durch Suizid zu verlieren.
Es ist nötig,
diesen Menschen zu helfen.
Es ist sinnvoll,
weil es auch wirksam ist.
Ich bringe gerne die Analogie
zur Situation,
wie wir sie am Platzspitz
mit der offenen Drogenszene
vor vielen Jahren hatten.
Man sah, dass es
einen Paradigmenwechsel brauchte -
weg von der reinen Repression.
Diese braucht es übrigens unbedingt
auch im Bereich der Paraphilien.
Es braucht eine Strafverfolgung.
Aber das alleine reicht nicht.
Es braucht auch gute Diagnostik
und Hilfestellung.
Dort hinken wir deutlich hinterher.
Ich bin froh, wenn verschiedene
Teilangebote zusammenkommen,
die so halbwegs funktionieren.
Möglicherweise auch unter dem Lead
des Netzwerks "Kein Täter werden"
aus der Berliner Charité,
damit ein internationaler Standard
entstehen kann.
Es gibt einen ganz klaren Fokus
auf Verhaltenskontrolle.
Das Therapieziel ist: keine Delikte.
Und zu schauen,
wie man jetzt damit lebt.
Man trainiert und macht Übungen,
z.B. mit einem Fantasietagebuch:
"Wie kann ich
mit einer Fantasie umgehen,
wenn ich weiss, dass sie irgendwann
im illegalen Bereich landet?"
Man kann in der Fantasie
eine Weiche stellen,
damit es nicht
in den illegalen Bereich geht.
"Was mache ich,
wenn ich in der Stadt
eine minderjährige Person sehe,
die mich sexuell anspricht?"
"Lasse ich die Fantasie zu
und schwelge in ihr
oder kann ich sie unterbrechen?"
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Grüezi.
Es freut mich ausserordentlich,
Sie zur Neulancierung unseres
Präventionsprojektes zu begrüssen.
Das Projekt "Kein Täter werden"
der Charité in Berlin
ist Pionierarbeit
eines grossen Teams.
Pionierin hier in der Schweiz,
in einem kleineren Rahmen,
ist Monika Egli-Alge.
Wir kennen uns seit vielen Jahren
aus der praktischen Arbeit.
Georg
war einer der ersten Betroffenen,
die unser Angebot
in Anspruch nahmen.
Georg beging
gemäss eigenen Angaben nie Delikte
und konsumierte
keine Missbrauchsabbildungen.
Georgs sexuelle Aktivität
besteht ausschliesslich
aus Masturbation und Fantasien.
Niemand weiss davon.
Immer wieder Phasen der Traurigkeit,
Verzweiflung und Hoffnungslosigkeit.
Es kommen
so intensive Suizidgedanken dazu,
dass eine Hospitalisierung
in einer psychiatrischen Klinik
notwendig wird
und er da mit seiner
schweren Depression behandelt wird.
Das hat er sich nicht ausgesucht,
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Wenn ich gefragt werde,
warum wir das eigentlich machen,
sage ich jeweils: "Im Grunde
bin ich eine Kinderschützerin."
Dieser Aspekt,
dass Täterarbeit Prävention ist,
macht mir sehr Eindruck.
Vielen Dank.
* Applaus *
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Ich arbeitete zuerst
mit Familien und Kindern,
die Opfererfahrungen gemacht haben.
Die Arbeit jetzt
ist für mich eine Möglichkeit,
durch dieses Angebot
und unser Engagement
weitere bzw. überhaupt Übergriffe
auf Kinder zu verhindern.
Das ist Kinderschutz.
Man kann nicht Opfer stärken,
damit es weniger Übergriffe gibt.
Die Verantwortung für den Übergriff
liegt bei der Täterschaft,
nicht beim Opfer,
darum muss man dort ansetzen.
(Christina) Für mich war immer klar
- ich sage das ganz salopp:
Wenn ein Pädophiler
ein Kind missbraucht,
gehört der Schwanz ab und er an den
Füssen aufgehängt und getrocknet.
Sie wurden von mir
aufs Schärfste verurteilt.
Da sehe ich keinen Menschen mehr.
Das ist ein Monster.
Ich konnte mir nicht vorstellen,
dass er das hat.
Ich dachte: "Alle, aber nicht er."
Plötzlich ist jemand davon
betroffen, der einem nahesteht.
Das geht so weit auseinander,
das ist unvorstellbar.
In der Gesellschaft
besteht diese Stammtischmeinung.
Man kann erst Meinungen ändern,
wenn man sich intensiv
mit dem Thema auseinandersetzt
und bereit ist,
sich auf das Thema einzulassen.
Vorher gibt es die Meinung
und die ist einfach so.
Ich habe mir auch schon
mit anderen Fotos angeschaut.
Jemand sagte dann:
"Der sieht aus wie ein Pädo."
Da kann ich nichts sagen,
weil man merken würde,
wie wichtig mir das Thema ist.
Man würde merken,
dass ich betroffen bin.
Was mache ich dann?
Ich kann ja nicht sagen:
"Mein Mann ist pädophil."
Dann könnten wir
unsere Koffer packen und gehen.
Ich würde gerne
extrovertierter darüber sprechen
und an der Gesellschaft rütteln,
aber das ist nicht einfach,
wenn man irgendwo wohnt
und privat und beruflich
einen Status hat. Das geht nicht.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es in
jedem Bekanntenkreis jemanden damit.
Und weil die Gesellschaft
so urteilt,
trauen sich viele nicht,
ein Anzeichen zu machen
oder jemanden darauf anzusprechen:
"Ich habe ein Problem,
ich brauche Hilfe."
Ich kann
von meiner Haftzeit sprechen:
Ich hatte viele Fragen zu dem Thema,
die nicht beantwortet wurden.
Ich kam an den Punkt,
an dem ich sagte:
"Ich bringe mich um,
ich habe keine Kraft mehr,
mich mit mir und meiner Neigung
auseinanderzusetzen."
"Ich mag nicht mehr.
Jetzt ist fertig."
Dank viel Zufall
und einer guten Portion Gespür
bin ich heute hier.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Viele Leute haben Mühe damit,
dass man ein Kind überhaupt begehrt.
Können Sie das verstehen?
- (Pascal) Ja, klar.
Für mich war es anfangs auch schwer,
dass ich Kinder begehre.
Jedes Kind, das missbraucht wird -
egal, wie -, ist eines zu viel.
Aber es ist ein Fakt,
dass es Leute gibt, die das haben.
Statt eine Person, die Hilfe sucht,
runterzumachen oder zu beschimpfen,
sollte man ihr dabei helfen,
trotzdem normal leben zu können.
Ich habe genug davon,
das zu verheimlichen
und so zu tun,
als wäre alles ganz "normal".
Es blieb mir ein Satz
aus der letzten Stunde hängen.
Da sagten Sie nämlich,
dass Sie eigentlich nirgends
so richtig sich selber sein können.
Das ist schon schwierig.
Dann kommt die Frage,
wie es mit einer Freundin,
einer Frau, mit Kindern aussieht.
Was sagen Sie dann?
- Ja ...
"Ich habe noch keine Partnerin
gefunden."
Das hilft manchmal.
Dann sagen sie:
"Okay, du bist noch jung."
Okay, ich bin mit meinen 30 Jahren
noch ziemlich jung,
aber am liebsten
würde ich dazu stehen können.
Dieses Doppelleben ist so mühsam.
Ein Doppelleben ist immer heikel.
Wir stellen in der Gesellschaft
den Automatismus fest,
dass Pädophile Kinderschänder seien.
Das erleben wir in unserem Alltag
als sehr hinderlich.
Das belastet die Betroffenen
zusätzlich
und wirkt nicht risikomindernd.
Das verleitet die Betroffenen
eher dazu,
noch weniger zu sagen,
noch intransparenter zu sein,
noch mehr
in ihrem Doppelleben zu sein.
Ich fahre jetzt nach Zürich
zur Gründungsversammlung des Vereins
"Kein Täter werden Suisse" -
in Anlehnung
an das Projekt in Deutschland,
das sozusagen
unser Mutterprojekt ist.
Für die Gründung
trifft sich Monika Egli-Alge
mit den Verantwortlichen
der Universitären Psychiatrischen
Kliniken Basel, Genf und Zürich.
Hallo, Elmar. Willkommen.
- Hallo.
Der grosse Moment.
John Köhl? Monika, freut mich.
- Genau. Mich auch.
Maximilian. Hi.
Schön, bist du hier.
Bist du extra aus Berlin angereist?
- Ja.
Das schätzen wir sehr.
Ich begrüsse euch alle
ganz herzlich.
Wir reisten schon ein paarmal
nach Berlin
und konnten einen guten Austausch
mit euch aufbauen.
Ich freue mich, das begleiten
und mit unseren Erkenntnissen
unterstützen zu dürfen.
Kannst du etwas zur Homepage sagen?
Läuft die schon?- Ja.
Es gibt auch
ein zunehmendes Interesse.
Ich habe diese Logik übernommen,
weil wir sehen,
dass viele Angehörige
sich informieren möchten -
und auch sehr viele Zuweiser.
Darüber haben wir auch gesprochen.
Das ist etwas, das wir
ziemlich schnell angehen müssen.
Dann fordere ich zur Wahl auf
und frage,
wer dafür ist,
dass Monika Egli-Alge
das Präsidium für eine Amtszeit
von zwei Jahren übernimmt?
Herzlichen Glückwunsch der
Gründungspräsidentin des Vereins.
Danke schön. Vielen Dank.
"Kein Täter werden Suisse"
gibt es ab jetzt.
Vielen Dank. Ich würde gerne
mit euch darauf anstossen.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Danke.
Zum Wohl, Maximilian. Danke.
Ich denke,
das ist bedeutend für die Welt,
für die Schweiz,
für die Kinder und die Betroffenen,
für die das Angebot gedacht ist.
Global betrachtet ist festzustellen,
dass fast nichts getan wird,
obwohl die Zahlen
sexuellen Kindesmissbrauchs
so hoch sind in der Welt.
Solche Netzwerke sind Leuchttürme,
die vielleicht
auch den Ideenhorizont
von Politikerinnen und Politikern
und Fachkräften erweitern können,
damit sie das als Baustein
einer umfassenden
Präventionsstrategie sehen
und das auch so übernehmen
und adaptieren.
(Martin)
Ich merke einfach, wie gut es tut,
mit jemandem, der nicht vom Fach
ist, darüber zu sprechen -
egal, ob Journalisten
oder sonst jemand.
Jemand, der das
aus einer anderen Perspektive sieht.
Die Gesellschaft muss lernen,
die Augen und Ohren aufzumachen
und sich dem zu stellen,
zu sagen, dass das
ein Teil der Gesellschaft ist.
Es ist nicht schön
und nicht einfach,
aber wenn wir uns als Gesellschaft
öffnen und es enttabuisieren,
machen wir auch Opferschutz.
Man kann nicht wegschauen.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Wenn man heute
öffentlich darüber spricht,
ruiniert man sich, weil die
Gesellschaft noch nicht so weit ist.
Man sollte kritisch darüber sprechen
und Taten auch wirklich verurteilen,
das ist wichtig,
aber als Gesellschaft
offener darüber sprechen,
damit die Leute mit dieser Präferenz
keine Angst davor haben müssen,
das zuzugeben.
Dass die Gesellschaft sagt:
"Ja, du hast das."
Es gibt genügend Fachstellen,
an die man sich wenden kann,
und die einem helfen,
mit dieser Neigung umzugehen.
(Pascal) Niemand möchte mit einem
Menschen zu tun haben, der das hat.
Haben Sie die Hoffnung,
dass sich das noch ändert?
Vielleicht, wenn ich alt bin.
Aber mit 50
muss ich mich nicht mehr outen.
Dann ist anderes wichtiger.
Wie wollen Sie gesehen werden?
Als Mensch.
Als Mensch, der das halt hat.
Ich habe das Ziel, sagen zu können:
"Das bin ich.
Ich bin so, wie ich bin."
"Ich kann nichts dafür."
Ich möchte kein Mitleid dafür.
Das bringt mir nichts.
Ich möchte, dass man mich versteht
und mir nicht den Tod wünscht.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021